bonsoir très heureuse de vous retrouver
avec Émilie pierre Patrick Mohamed
Mathieu salut les amis bonsoir on est
ensemble jusqu'à 20h55 mais c'est à VOUS
devient ce soir c'est à eux jeux de mots
subtils pour allier la chasse aux œufs
et l'envie de consacrer l'intégralité de
l'émission à des invités qu'on admire
pour leur engagement pour leur parcours
et pour leur talent et c'est parti pour
duel en famille on se lundi de Pâques
bonjour à tous à la maison les bras
chargés de chocolat et ben oui ça y est
avec le public les cloches sont passées
on est allés chercher les œufs j'espère
que vous allez bien on se lundi certains
auront un coup un peu particulier le
goût de notre blague annuelle peut-être
quand on enlève le haut mot cacao cela
fait de caca du caca et malgré la hausse
du caca où on va chercher le caca beurre
de caca et poudre de caca on dit que
c'est bon pour le moral vrai ou faux
c'est très bon pour le moral
mais regardez tout ce qu'il y a ça
libérer le circuit de la récompense
regardez sa procure il y a plein de
substances machin le circulaire
récompense plaisir réconfort détente
antidépresseur naturel si ça c'est pas
bon pour le moral à demain
ici 3 j'en ai deux ah j'en ai trois j'ai
on va parler vous avez bien compris non
pas œuf mais chocolat tout de suite ça
avec gimelo c'est déguisé
pour Émilie que pour moi voir les gens
c'est en tournée dans toute la France
oui les sacrément garni
oui
ce sont des couverts une deuxième
passion cultivée du caca 1500 mètres de
caca
se mélangent à notre salive le caca
liquide
[Rires]
ils avaient caché des rognons de veau
dans les buissons il y avait des
chapelets de saucisses suspendus dans
les arbres des paupiettes dans les
bégonias il était tout content merci les
enfants encore un salami dans les
tulipes joyeuses Pâques les cloches
résonnent c'est-à-dire qu'elle
réfléchissent ça parce qu'on a deux
raisonner on a raisonné avec aïe alors
on a mis à y ça veut dire réfléchir et
ça vient du latin ratio pensez à
rationnel donc on a gardé le a puis de
rajouter le i pour avoir et à côté de ça
on a raisonné e accent aigu lui vient du
latin raisonnaré ben ça c'est les
cloches qui font ding dong un cheval
[Musique]
très bien joué alors c'est embêtant
parce que à l'écrit l'ordinateur il vous
corrige pas et alors là c'est génial
alors demain en allant au boulot vous
prenez votre PDG en quatre yeux et vous
lui dites oh Monsieur le Directeur
qu'est-ce que vous résonnez bien alors
lui tout a son ego ben il a compris que
vous vendiez ses qualités
intellectuelles alors qu'en fait vous
êtes défoulé en traitant de cloche ok
pardon
qui veut dire je peux rien faire c'est
comme ça évidemment mais non ok bon
après j'imagine que tu la connais aussi
voilà allez c'est parti
avez-vous senti dans le aller et salut
un petit ta gueule on va y aller 17000
pour une omelette et pas n'importe
laquelle un sel de la confrérie mondiale
des chevaliers de l'omelette géant de
Bessières près de Toulouse ça s'invente
pas une tradition à chaque lundi de
Pâques depuis 1973 50 ans plus tard la
manifestation attire des milliers de
visiteurs dans la joie et la bonne
humeur écoutez
le temps de cuisson
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et encore une fois le public est venu la
déguster gratuitement et en nombre à
noter la poêle géante mesure pas moins
de 4 mètres de diamètre tout de même
ma peau s'est habituée à ne pas avoir de
crème donc à ne pas être nourris entre
guillemets et donc je vais pas me mettre
dans ce pli là parce que sinon après il
faudrait que j'en mette tout le temps
il y a plusieurs plis mais ça va je suis
fripé je suis fripédia
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est ça ambiance ambiance un
minet total internationale français rudy
Gobert a frappé son propre coéquipier
Kyle Anderson lors d'un temps mort
Minnesota s'apprête à discuter le
playing tour de qualification
supplémentaire pour accéder au fameux
playoff de la NBA l'Américain reproché
visiblement à notre cher français deux
erreurs commises en défense le coup est
parti tout simple le monde de la NBA est
décidément plein de surprises aux
États-Unis il n'y a pas que des pom-pom
girls avant les matchs il y a aussi des
courses de bébé
de plus en plus tendance les franchises
américaines en ont organisé plusieurs
dizaines cette année des lots sont à
gagner pour le premier à franchir la
ligne d'arrivée
de quoi galvaniser certains parents qui
semblent faire totalement abstraction
des larmes de leurs enfants on enchaîne
avec Indiana Jones l'explorateur qui est
un peu comme la famille Le Pen puisque
quand il est là les nazis ne sont jamais
très loin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]